If you're a superhero fan, 2018 already looks
to be an exciting year.
Movies featuring Black Panther, the Flash,
and Aquaman are all scheduled, and there's
also a little movie called Avengers: Infinity
War.
But one 2018 release is absolutely guaranteed
to to rock your world: Deadpool 2.
The Merc With a Mouth is returning with several
fan favorites from the first movie — and
the cinematic debut of some more classic comic
book characters.
We've got two crisp high-fives worth of reasons
Deadpool 2 will blow everyone away.
"OK guys lets get out there and make a difference."
"(you know what to do)"
John Wick approved
If you want to get someone excited about Deadpool
2, you only need to use two words: John Wick.
After some behind-the-scenes drama that caused
Deadpool director Tim Miller to bail on the
sequel, the project landed David Leitch to
take up the job.
Leitch injected fresh energy into the action
genre with the first John Wick, taking a tired
revenge premise and building it into something
completely awesome.
If Leitch can marry the sleek, stylish action
of John Wick with the crude, off-the-wall
humor of Deadpool, he'll create a superhero
movie like nothing we've seen.
Or at least a worthy successor.
Sequel skewering
It wouldn't be Deadpool if it didn't poke
fun at itself, and a Deadpool sequel is bound
to go the same way.
As excited as fans get about the return of
their favorite heroes and villains, too often
the sequels just lack the spark that made
the originals so good.
Fortunately, Deadpool 2 is setting out to
put unnecessary super-sequels in their place.
As producer Simon Kinberg put it,
"The sort of glut or saturation of these movies
and the proliferation of sequels is definitely
something we'll play around with."
Even your reluctant friend who can't stand
each year's endless superhero sequels and
reboots might get a kick out of this phenomenon
being brutally savaged by Deadpool's sarcasm.
Deadpool and friends
Deadpool 2 will be expanding its roster of
characters by at least two.
One will be Domino, a mutant with a very special
ability that can only be described as "good
luck."
When she wants something to happen, she can
greatly increase the odds.
In the comics, she's had several run-ins with
Deadpool, though their exact relationship
in the upcoming sequel remains unclear.
In addition to potentially bringing Domino,
to life on the big screen, the movie will
also likely fulfill its promise from the end
of the first one:
"The sequel?
We're gonna have Cable.
Amazing character.
Bionic arm.
Time Travel."
In the comics, Cable has a pretty complex
backstory involving time travel and a weird
techno-organic virus, a mashup of time paradoxes
and clones that any movie studio would have
a hard time translating to the screen.
Basically, a standalone Cable movie ain't
gonna happen.
But if Deadpool 2 got ahold of him, Cable
doesn't have to be anything but a badass,
bullet-slinging future-warrior — the guy
we all want to see — and be right at home
in Deadpool's bonkers cinematic world.
Look no further than the Deadpool video game
for proof of their perfect double act:
"This has got to be the dumbest idea you've
ever had.
The risk is considerable.
This is my..."
"Great Cable, awesome thanks, see ya, goodbye!"
Hello X-Force
To casual fans, some of these new additions
to the Deadpool sequel may seem a little random.
After all, a time-traveling cyborg and lady
luck seem out of place in the somewhat grounded
reality of Deadpool's corner of the X-Men
cinematic universe.
But as with all things Hollywood, there are
bigger things on the horizon.
In 20th Century Fox's case, that means an
X-Force film.
In the comics, the X-Force was formed by Cable
as a mutant team that specialized in "wetwork"
— a fancy way of saying hacking up bad guys.
The initial lineup featured Cable as the leader
and Domino as one of his ace soldiers, and
now both of these characters are slated to
be in Deadpool 2.
And with Ryan Reynolds reportedly co-writing
the X-Force script, chances are good that
Deadpool 2 will start laying the foundation
for the X-Force.
Returning favorites
It's not all new names and faces for Deadpool
2 — all the best parts of the first movie
are coming back, too.
So far, the sequel is confirmed to feature
Deadpool's main squeeze Vanessa, Negasonic
Teenage Warhead, Colossus, and our favorite
taxi driver since Robert De Niro: Dopinder.
"Dopinder, this is no way to win Geeta's heart
back.
(I'm so proud of you)."
There's also a chance that Vanessa will play
a bigger role in the action.
In the comics, the character Vanessa is based
on is a mutant with the codename Copycat,
who has the ability to steal the appearance
and powers of other characters.
More likely, though, Deadpool's just gonna
stick Vanessa in a flashy outfit and make
a joke about it.
Yeah, that's more Wade's style.
More superhero mockery
For better or worse, we're swimming in superhero
movies for the foreseeable future.
From Warner Bros. establishing their own cinematic
universe to the unending march of the MCU,
it seems like there's always a cape, web,
or magic hammer hanging out at your local
movie theater.
One of the things that made Deadpool so funny
was the way it relentlessly lampooned these
other superhero movies, from the opening credits
to Deadpool's breakdown of Angel's "superhero
landing."
"Superhero landing.
You know that's really hard on your knees.
It's really impracticable, they all do it."
And, of course, the meta-mockery of Reynolds'
failed Green Lantern movie.
"Please don't make the super-suit green!
Or animated!"
One simple reason to be excited about Deadpool
2 is that there are so many more movies for
it to make fun of.
Since Deadpool, we've seen Logan, Captain
America: Civil War, Batman v Superman, Doctor
Strange, and Suicide Squad.
And by the time Deadpool 2 comes out Spider-Man:
Homecoming will have been released, as well
as Guardians of the Galaxy Volume 2.
If Deadpool's gonna pick at superheroes like
we know he will, he's got plenty of material
to work with this time around.
Low-budget creativity
With all of Deadpool's gorgeous visuals and
slo-mo sarcasm, you might be surprised that
it was made with a budget of only $58 million.
In the world of superhero cinema, where bloated
films like Batman v Superman clock in at budgets
of $250 million and beyond, Deadpool was essentially
made for chump change.
This forced the creative team to put an emphasis
on characters, relationships, and humor.
Deadpool 2 co-writer Paul Wernick has insisted
the sequel will also be relatively cheap,
saying,
"We don't want $150 million to go make the
next movie, because that's not Deadpool.
Deadpool doesn't lift cities up into the air
or battle aliens coming down to earth."
Taking this interview at face value, it means
the sequel will see a continued focus on humor,
relationships, and comparatively low-stakes
action — great news for those of us who
really appreciated the character-driven original.
That amazing trailer
If you saw Logan in theaters, you were treated
to a doozie of a teaser — the Deadpool 2
promo that disguised itself as the beginning
of the Logan movie.
Based on that alone, you can bet Deadpool
2 is going to blow us all away, with references
to Cable's real name and the best Stan Lee
cameo yet.
"Wow, nice suit."
"Zip it Stan Lee!"
It's a solid assurance that the original's
violence, humor, and self-deprecating humor
remain in force.
Also, what's up with that Firefly poster?
Just a nod to Vanessa actress Morena Baccarin?
A jab at Fox for canceling the show?
With Deadpool, it could mean anything...or
nothing.
All we know right now is that Deadpool 2 is
going to be amazing.
How amazing?
"I'm touching myself tonight."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!